hello Mexico will be hosting a
conference of the parties 16 cop16 in
Cancun this December and we are we want
to learn from the mistake we make
Copenhagen being we are trying to bring
all together all the countries to the
table we want to hear all the voices we
want to understand all the interest in
order to reach a real consistent
repulsive agreement to tackle climate
change the evidence coming from the
academic searching is overwhelming and
today all the problems that we have
associated with climate change are
affecting the lives of common citizens
around the world in order to tackle
climate change we need to work together
we need to understand the different
point of view the different concerns
different interests of not only by
developed but also by developing
countries and what we need to do is to
build an economic framework in order to
start with the right economic incentives
to motivate and stimulate the
participation of all countries and
governments 13 10 matches so what we
want to do is to put in actions these
phones coming from the green cone and in
order to under the result based
principles start to work against climate
change meaning in the developing
countries we can do a lot of things we
Mexico are working really hard in terms
of preventing deforestation
reforestation areas we are reducing the
laterally our emissions 15 million
stones by 2012 year and we have a
commitment of thirty percent of
reduction from business as usual by the
year to 2020 and fifty percent by the
year 2050 so we are working with other
countries we are organizing the cops
team will be very difficult to reach
agreement we must to do that we have not
no more time to wait for the world and
we will be waiting for you in Cancun and
please give us all the super coming from
the civil society NGOs in order to get
new momentum and get a very successful
meeting of cop 16 in Cancun Mexico thank
you